this thing that we're embarking it's a
plot
to convince people that something is
true which will only be true if we can
convince a whole lot of people that it
is true
somebody said you know you have one
person believes something crazy and this
is a psychotic two people believe
something crazy it's called a folla ado
it's still in the realm of pathology
three people it's a delusion four people
a cult five people a religion and six
people a political party
so yes i think that's true that that
um
that's
right but
it's like so what's going to reach these
people in this chili joint in
albuquerque you know it's it'll be it'll
be
some idea
sung through the media simultaneously
because soon we're all going to be wired
up you know so intensely in contact by
the thrust and movement of technology
that some idea that we are discussing
here at the level of language nouns and
purpose of what will will some rock guy
some bob dylan somebody you know some
group will sing it into the wires and
before the the hucksters can manipulate
it for a profit it already penetrates
the the people in albuquerque it's in
there yes so that so this this is very
good this shows why it is that to in
answer to this question what should be
done
the answer is
art
has to be created on a massive scale a
small scale everywhere all the time
that that is the way to reach all these
people too and
the thing
that is so challenging to me or why i'm
impelled to even be in the
ridiculous position that i'm in is
because
what these psychedelics show you what
these plants show you in an hour and a
half span of time is more art
than the human race has produced in the
last 5 000 years that's the art bank
that's what the shamans knew and if
we're talking about transforming the
world through transforming images
through feeding new raw stuff into the
linguistic hopper then we need to hit
the main vein of the art pool that is in
this other dimension and then it will
just come gushing out i mean i always
have this feeling you know when i hear
the dead or the stones or somebody new
who's good and people say you know how
how was the band
and no matter how good the band is i
always think it could be so much better
you know and when i go to art shows no
matter how good it is it could be so
much better why is it so hard for us
to grab
this thing called beauty
and bring it down into our world when as
shamans as spiritual voyagers we can be
with
so much of it and yet bring back
so little it's like we're people who go
to the ocean with a cup in hand
you know and we swim in the ocean and we
sail on the ocean and then we return to
our drought-stricken territory with a
teaspoon
and say you know this is this is what i
brought from the ocean
so yeah i think the the the impulse to
create art the impulse to set metaphors
loose
and to create a permission
for transformation because everything is
held up in the one should
one mustn't
we do it this way kind of stuff yeah
which is nothing more than kind of
cultural fascism and small-mindedness
language can do anything this is
something that the mushroom this is one
of its aphorisms you know language can
do anything and then then so i say to
the mushroom then let it
save us
you know because that's what we need to
do let us build a ladder of words an
analogical engine a bark of verses a
wagon of phrases and get ourselves out
of here
it's that sort of thing and these kinds
of structures are really to my mind
ultimately to be seen as words
you know this is an utterance it's like
the viconian utterances that punctuate
finnegan's wake it's a word from a
higher order of space and time whether
it's coming to us from benevolent
extraterrestrials or
deeply concerned bodhisattvas or the
over mind of the collectivity it really
doesn't matter what matters is that we
must receive transmit and concretize
the word in order to create a forward
escape out of the contradiction of
the contradictions
in the world that are the legacy of bad
language that's brought us this far
it's a healing of language
[Music]
you